للشهداء اسماء وقصص
وسنخبركم جزءا من قصه دانيه عدس
ضيع كل فرحتنا الاحتلال
الاحتلال ضيع كل فرحتنا وكل حياتنا مع بعض
كانت تتحضر لزفافها عندما انطلقت مقاتلات
اسرائيليه وجهتها غزه قصفت المقاتله
الاسرائيليه منزلا مجاورا لعائله دانيه
لكن ما تقول اسرائيل انها ضربات جراحيه لا
تترك في الواقع سوى جراح نازفه في قلوب
سكان غزه وعن بعض الا الموت يفرقنا مع بعض
وفعلا هاي الموت اللي هو فرغنا عن بعض
يحاول محمد التماسك لكنه فقد حب حياته كما
يقول
وتغالب والدتها الدموع نادت على ابنتيها
دون جواب اخذ فرحه عيلتين هذا الاحتلال
مني اخذ اعز ما املك اخذ اولادي
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل اخذوا اولادي مني
استشهدت دانيه على الفور ثم ايمان متاثره
بجراحها كنت اتمنى اتمنى اني ازف بنتي
بالطرحه البيضاء
زفيتها بالكفن الابيض ثانيه وايمان
وثمانيه مدنيين اخرين استشهدوا في الضربه
الصاروخيه بينهم اربعه اطفال الله